what could be a key detail about how
you'll be able to play call of duty 4
modern warfare remastered version has
come to light I'm Lucy and welcome to
your I lost my kill streak gamespot news
update as call of duty fansite Charlie
Intel spotted modern warfare remastered
website has been updated with a line of
text that suggests you may need the call
of duty infinite warfare disc inserted
to play the game as announced previously
modern warfare remastered is a
digital-only game that is available only
through infinite warfare premium
editions which start at eighty dollars
the line of text in question reads
modern warfare remastered is a full game
download game disc must be inserted to
play modern warfare remastered internet
connection required activation also
directs people to this faq page but it
doesn't have more details about the game
disc must be inserted part Charlie Intel
reported that if you're buying infinite
warfare digitally this does not apply to
you since you obviously weren't happy
disc one reason why Activision may
require you to insert the infinite
warfare disc to play modern warfare
remastered is that it would eliminate
the ability for people to sell their
copy of the game and continue to be able
to play modern warfare remastered
activation hasn't said if the remastered
version will ever be sold on its own
though it also hasn't ruled it out we've
reached out to Activision in an attempt
to get more details and we will of
course update you when we hear back so
are you itching to replay modern warfare
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at least
James games but more on call of duty
make sure you keep it gamespot
you